qualche tempo fa ho trovato in un
cassetto una vecchia pratica già aperta
e ho trovato un contratto scritto da un
praticante di mio nonno con la sua con
alcune sue annotazioni a penna ma
confrontato con quello che vedevo sul
monitor un contratto con tanti markup
colorati e mi sono domandato ma che cosa
vuol dire essere professionista oggi
come si fa a diventarlo guardate questa
foto vedete il professionista più
anziano signor l'artigiano
l'imprenditore di prima generazione che
forte di una conoscenza acquisita nel
tempo
insegna ad un ragazzo più giovane il
quale è ben consapevole di apprendere da
un maestro ed è disposto in cambio di
lavorare per molte ore al giorno
essendo pagato molto poco anche nulla
vero praticanti e si accetta tutto ciò
perché sa che un giorno toccherà anche a
lui questo stesso onere e onore
ora guardate questa foto il più giovane
e davanti è lui che comanda
insegna alla persona è molto più vecchia
di lui come possibile come è stato
possibile tutto questo
nell'arco di un decennio grazie a quella
che si può definire una nuova scoperta
del fuoco internet sembra che si sia
invertito il flusso e la direzione del
trasferimento intergenerazionale delle
competenze anche nel mondo delle
professioni delle aziende per la prima
volta nella storia
sembra che siano i giovani a dover
insegnare ai vecchi
tutto questo è stato possibile grazie
abbiamo detto ad internet internet non
ha cambiato solo la nostra concezione
dello spazio del tempo e ha accellerato
drammatica
le nostre vite internet ha creato uno
spazio di condivisione globale la rete
in cui milioni di persone hanno
riversato la propria esperienza la
propria conoscenza i propri saperi
imparati nel tempo grazie a questo
ciascuno di noi in maniera gratuita in
maniera immediata può accedere un
patrimonio di informazioni infinito e
può senza recarsi in una biblioteca
senza stare a bottega da qualcuno senza
lavorare in un'azienda di uno studio
professionale imparare quanto c'è di più
nuovo al mondo bello no
secondo me non è un caso che oggi si
parli tanto di start up e di spazio di
coworking e siano diventato il nuovo
mantra non è a mio avviso la crisi
economica un'altra parte una nuova le
nuove generazioni giorni logiche si sa
che imparino che vadano a bottega da
qualcuno che non ha più nulla da
insegnarci di nuovo è cambiato sono
cambiati completamente i modelli i
parametri tanto vale rischiar sera da
soli iniziare qualcosa di nuovo
prendendo dalla rete quello che serve e
cercando di offrire soluzioni nuove
senza dover lavorare gratis per altri
magari lavorando invece insieme ad altri
coetanei che hanno competenze diverse
apprese sfruttando ancora una volta la
rete
guardate io me ne parlò non per sentito
dire
quattro anni fa proprio grazie a un
ragazzo conosciuto su internet molto più
giovane di me abbiamo creato una start
up che ha generato un software che a sua
volta genera documenti legali su
internet e rigenera in 10 lingue diverse
e abbiamo clienti da 50 paesi
vendiamo diritto di tutto il mondo bello
ma non voglio parlarvi di questo voglio
parlarvi sempre del trasferimento
generazionale delle competenze e ora
pensare alla generazione non più giovane
ma la generazione
chi è stato un nostro maestro
improvvisamente grazie a internet di
nuovo una generazione di imprenditori di
professionisti che aveva imparato sua
volta dei propri maestri un certo serie
di competenze si è trovato un analfabeta
2.0 è arrivato il processo civile
telematico è arrivata la fatturazione
elettronica la firma digitale un sacco
di novità tutte insieme
difficile stare al passo e ben presto
anche lo stesso esercizio dei diritti
civili per questa generazione diventerà
complesso il dialogare con la pubblica
amministrazione richiedere un
certificato persino votare richiederà
l'uso esclusivo gli strumenti
tecnologici rischiamo quindi che
un'intera generazione venga estromessa
ma a questo punto mi voglio fare una
domanda perché io me la sono posta
siamo sicuri che questa nuova
generazione sia autosufficiente non
abbia bisogno di maestri abbiamo la rete
dalla quale possiamo apprendere
qualsiasi cosa e dall'altro lato vi
faccio una domanda vi fareste difendere
da un avvocato che ha imparato solo da
banche dati da un medico che ha imparato
solo su internet è una domanda sempre
più attuale e per questo ho pensato di
rivolgerla ad un professionista ad
eccezione da molto tempo
l'avvocato marco tullio cicerone
cicerone per i suoi tempi è stato un
grande innovatore e stato il primo a
utilizzare la scienza retorica per
vincere in giudizio per convincere il
giudice è l'arte del persuadere ma
cicerone rimasto famoso fine giorni noi
perché è riuscito a scandagliare nel
profondo l'animo umano grazie proprio
alla sua esperienza come avvocato e se
ci pensate bene ciascuno avvocato a da
duemila anni sempre lo stesso cliente un
uomo
siamo tutti prima di essere
professionisti imprenditori uomini al
servizio di altri uomini
e non è un caso quindi che
a stanford nel corso di computer science
siano necessari crediti in materie
umanistiche il lo strumento senza un
fine non ha alcun senso
quindi mi domando tutto si sta evolvendo
i recinti delle professioni non sono più
validi non ci sono più solo avvocati
notai e commercialisti sono avvocati che
scrivono software ci sono matematici che
scrivono algoritmi per verificare le
decisi la correttezza delle decisioni
dei giudici
ci sono ingegneri che scrivono smart
contract cioè contratti auto i seguenti
attraverso la blog chain ma un po come
con huber o con airbnb tutti noi
possiamo essere ogni giorno
professionisti o clienti albergatori o
clienti
possiamo essere maestri o allievi quindi
la mia domanda è chi è il professionista
3.0 e soprattutto intorno alla domanda
iniziale è possibile che qui ci si sta
ora una generazione autosufficiente che
non ha più bisogno di maestre
io credo che la risposta sia no credo
che abbiamo una cassetta degli attrezzi
molto più ampia
molti più strumenti la rete brano
l'early fondamentale ma solo attraverso
un'alleanza tra generazioni riusciremo a
rispondere alle esigenze di un uomo che
vive di esperienza anche l'esperienza
umana e guardate a me piacerebbe
moltissimo conoscere le opinioni così
come mi sarebbe piaciuto parlare con mio
nonno di questi stessi temi
e forse la tecnologia ci può dare uno
strumento utilizzate per favore questo
hashtag e scrivete le vostre opinioni
a chi non è capace può chiedere sempre
al suo vicino più giovane
grazie